A person sent in their signature test to ask to kind of go over it to understand what the signature test is looking at.
So the signature test, this part of it is testing for what's called cell-free DNA or CFDNA.
Cell-free DNA is the same thing that for those that have been with me for a number of years.
The same thing that the IBG test tested for.
So there's value in measuring cell-free DNA.
Matter of fact, you could do a Google search on cell-free DNA.
And it will tell you that cell-free DNA was really, you know, what it first was discovered to be able to be tested levels in the blood.
There's a lot of excitement because it can tell you if a person has cancer before a lot of other objective tests can tell you.
So it is still used in different tests, the cologard test that is very widely advertised on TV is a cell-free DNA test.
It's using that same technology. The IBG test that we used to do is a cell-free DNA test.
However, that company went out of business during COVID.
Is there a try to keep their prices down and sell to doctors like me to sell to patients where as like cologard using the exact same technology charges like $2,500.
But they're going only through insurance and only through medical doctors in order to make it a profitable business.
Signature does, you know, close through doctors like me and other doctors that are doing alternative care, but it's more expensive tests.
And that's where IBG had to either raise their price, either like triple their price to stay in business.
And they just could not get this and have the advertising budget. They're a small lab.
Even though they were clear for lab, they just couldn't stay in business.
So cell-free DNA can be measured at different times in the level of cell-free DNA.
It is not to then correspond to the level of, you know, cancer.
So if that level goes up, then the ideas that the cancer is getting worse if that level goes down and the cancer is getting better, you're recovering.
However, we have seen with when we used the IBG tests for the three years that they were in business, that that wasn't always the case.
And so just like any other test, you cannot count on one test.
This person's results actually show the cell-free DNA going down here over time.
One done earlier in 2023 to end of August, September, 2023 to this time that it's going down.
And the person's conditioning condition appears to be not moving in the same good direction seems to be moving in a worse direction sometime.
So it's very difficult to use one test to monitor this.
So I tell you even with doing a CT scan or an MRI or using tuber marker tests, you know, sometimes when you're actually getting better in your cancer's dying, the tuber marker test could spike giving you a false positive that you think you're getting worse.
The cell-free DNA can actually go down when the cancer's growing too.
So it can be confusing. Why is it because no test is perfect?
Even though things are a gold standard, there really isn't anything.
Now, visual presentation of the tuber in tests like a CT scan or an MRI may be considered the gold standard solely because
you can physically see that the size of the tumor is getting larger if you have a solid tumor and you could use a CT or an MRI.
A PET scan isn't technically a visual field test. It's measuring uptake of glucose and increase in metabolic rate.
But it's kind of the same line, whereas a blood test like this or a tuber marker test is measuring an outcome of cancer growth or cancer death.
So again, no test is perfect. You look at one test and you compare it with other objective tests.
One parent with subjective findings, meaning your symptoms and what else is going on in your body, how you're feeling, other signs like I'm getting fluid in my abdomen or I'm getting a sighties built up.
And the sighties is getting worse on a weekly basis, meaning they have to drain more each week.
That would be a sign that the cancer is getting worse or it's getting better. And I'm getting, you know, even though there was there was 1500 milligram milliliters taken out one time now, it's, you know, now we're only taking out 750 milliliters every week or every two weeks.
So that would be getting better. So you don't measure just one test. You look at as many tests as possible.